cuántos de ustedes se han sentido en
alguna ocasión con falta de motivación
interés entusiasmo o simplemente un
periodo de tristeza temporal o ansiedad
en la era moderna de la medicina la
filosofía parece ser usted está enfermo
hasta que no se demuestre lo contrario y
da la impresión que estamos viviendo en
un cuento de hadas encantados por
enfermedades ya no sólo las
tradicionales sino las inventadas
etiquetan dando nombre rotulando timidez
que de inmediato se transforma en fobia
social tristeza temporal que es
catalogada como depresión mayor falta de
motivación desde hace unos años como
trastorno por déficit motivacional o qué
decir del síndrome pre o post vacacional
que se dice en las oficinas hace poco
más de
30 años tuve la oportunidad de llegar a
este mundo y al igual que sé
y se etiquetan hombres este soy yo si
reconocen y hay algún experto en la sala
seguramente reconocerán que hay algo mal
con este niño podríamos decir que en la
actualidad
este niño puede tener intolerancia a la
glucosa diabetes hipertensión si el
rostro de mi madre lo dice vaya qué es
lo que tengo pero la pregunta real si
analizan con detención es qué es lo que
pasó ahí en el signo de interrogación
una producción a nivel abdominal que
pudiera tratarse de un tumor en temprano
etapa o bien un aneurisma
afortunadamente nací hace más de 30 años
pero poco después las cosas fueron
cambiando
con esa curiosidad que todo niño sano
posee tuve un sentimiento afectivo
físico emocional irresistible hacia los
juegos hacia los deportes extremos ella
es precisamente es lo que les mostraba
yo así jugaba yo cuando era niño
cualquiera podría pensar actualmente que
este niño pudiera tener trastorno por
déficit de atención o hiperactividad muy
probablemente esto fue lo responsable
hizo hizo estragos en mi cerebro y
terminé estudiando medicina
ya en la facultad de medicina de
permítanme contarles
conocido el caso de una paciente de 64
años de edad en el 2004 esta paciente se
le diagnosticó un tumor en la mama del
lado izquierdo
ella lo desconoce al paso de los años 12
para ser exacto me encontré con uno de
sus familiares le pregunté por la señora
la señora murió pero no murió de cáncer
murió de un infarto al corazón habría
que preguntarse si a esta paciente si lo
hubiera sometido a pruebas de
tratamiento confirmatorio para la lesión
que tenía seguramente se le habría
detectado cáncer se hubiera sometido a
estrés ansiedad depresión tratamientos
desagradables ella y sus médicos habrían
creído que se habría curado con éxito
aunque no hubiera vivido más tiempo pero
si era paciente de cáncer
afectaría su bienestar y su calidad de
vida porque existe cada vez un mayor
número de personas enfermas con o sin
algún daño en búsqueda de salud cuál es
el impacto que tiene el diagnosticar una
enfermedad que no va a progresar qué es
lo que nos mantiene saludables entonces
a lo largo de la vida
esta es una tabla no nos vamos a poner a
analizar pero si ustedes observan la
tendencia es una epidemia de diagnóstico
no una epidemia de cáncer lo que está
haciendo que se sobre detecte cada vez
más esta enfermedad esto lo podemos
analizar desde la teoría del caos una
nube o un torbellino desde el efecto
mariposa una nube pequeña no siempre
progresa a una nube monstruosa un
pequeño tumor no siempre progresa a una
lesión totalmente agresiva el
sobrediagnóstico como lo llamamos en
medicina es una anormalidad o condición
sin síntomas que no va a progresar puede
regresar o bien puede desaparecer y si
lo hace tan lentamente como en la
gráfica el paciente suele fallecer de
otra causa como el caso de la señora
esto tiene años
el pensador iván ilich hasta la
actualidad estudiando ser entre más
pacientes son detectados más son
diagnosticados más necesitan visitas al
médico más visitan visitas de
seguimiento más necesitan tratamiento y
eso como puede conllevar consecuencias
reales para los pacientes frecuentemente
resulta más fácil y rápido solicitar una
prueba de laboratorio que discutir a
profundidad si está será beneficiosa o
perjudicial para el paciente y habría
que preguntarse también si cuanta más
pruebas mejor cuantas más pruebas salga
uno de las consultas es mejor cuantas
más recetas salga uno de las consultas
es mejor por si fuera poco convivimos
con publicidad inagotable e
interminables sobre enfermedades que
podremos padecer en el futuro ya la
medicina no solamente tiene el hecho de
curar sino hacernos más felices más
bellos más inteligentes esto puede crear
de tensión dispersión discrepancia las
tres emes de la filosofía kaizen
japonesa para la mejora continua y
aplicable para cualquier profesión y más
aún para la profesión médica
una avalancha de asistencia médica
innecesaria daña a los pacientes física
mental y dilapida los recursos de los
bolsillos de cada una de las personas
junto con ese interés persecución
entusiasmo de diagnosticar por
diagnosticar
la creencia cultural de que más es mejor
puede conllevar consecuencias reales
para los pacientes más medicinas no
siempre es la mejor medicina durante los
próximos minutos
ustedes saldrán de aquí con herramientas
y bases clave que les permita
transformar su visión del mundo de la
medicina de este universo que esta
disciplina práctica social y profesional
ofrece de qué manera van a transformar
su visión de una manera compartida
colaborativa armónica articulada con su
médico formando parte de la toma de
decisiones
y no al revés de manera pasiva de manera
vertical donde uno parece que se
encuentra en la torre de marfil y otro
reducido a buen enfermo al buen paciente
el proceso de la toma de decisiones es
conjunto no aislado es la manera en la
que pueden participar
un ejemplo claro es la hipertensión
arterial
al paso de los años se ha bajado cada
vez más el umbral de diagnóstico así que
señores si quieren convertirse en
hipertensos ni siquiera se preocupen lo
más probable es que lo sean pero cuántas
personas están siendo afectadas cuáles
son los costos cuáles son los daños
cuánto tiene que haber de medios cuánto
tiene que haber de fines ante este otro
caso es la osteoporosis por eso existen
cada vez más medicamentos para poder
osteoporosis que para evitar caídas en
los ancianos para fracturas esto es los
umbrales cada vez más
actualmente ya con 120 29 uno tiene
presión arterial elevada sólo es normal
abajo de 120 hay muchísimas estrategias
que han surgido a lo largo del mundo
pero los médicos se han encargado de
solamente ver por una parte ver una
parte del problema sin ver la totalidad
de la problemática sin ver lo que hay la
obra de arte que hay detrás de cada
paciente
la medicina narrativa cómo podemos
entonces invertir parte de nuestro
tiempo y energía para resolver este esta
situación hay cinco conductores posibles
del short de diagnóstico en el cultural
la creencia cultural de que más es mejor
cambiar el sistema de salud mide más
cantidad que calidad la industria la
capacidad de ver hallazgos cada vez más
pequeños en las pruebas y los pacientes
y el público donde ustedes juegan un
importante no pongan un exceso de
confianza en un número o en una prueba
siempre hay algo más no se operan
radiografías se operan pacientes lo
importante es lo que usted tiene no lo
que tenga la radiografía la enfermedad
es la cara nocturna de la vida
sin duda una ciudadanía más pesada a
todos al nacer nos observan una doble
ciudadanía
la del mundo de los sanos y la de los
enfermos y aunque preferimos usar el
pasaporte bueno
tarde o temprano cada uno de nosotros se
ve obligado al menos durante algún
tiempo a identificarse como ciudadanos
de aquel otro mundo del mundo de los
enfermos ahí donde están las
enfermedades omnipresentes e inoportunas
como los celulares ya no los vemos de
tan familiares que son es imposible
pensar que la vida pase sin ellos no hay
que dejar de lado el viejo pensamiento
de los cirujanos o el viejo adagio
quirúrgico como le dicen los médicos un
buen cirujano sabe cómo operar otro sabe
cuándo operar y el mejor cuando no
operar realmente este paciente necesita
este diagnóstico estaría mejor sin él
realmente necesito este tratamiento
doctor o estaría mejor sin él el primer
paso para resolver este problema de
reconocer que existe ya quiere llegar el
filósofo puso el centro en la persona
individual de modo que estamos obligados
a actuar como hemos visto hoy esto no es
una opción es la única manera de avanzar
donde tú eres una pieza clave para la
tan anhelada medicina participativa
conjuntamente la toma de decisiones con
su médico cuestionen a su médico
realmente necesito este tratamiento
estaría mejor sin el doctor oiga y si no
me lo tomo puede tener algún efecto
adverso doctor en parte los médicos nos
hemos ido haciendo cargo de lo que
también puede ir mal todo lo que
realizamos con los médicos tiene un
beneficio y un grado de satisfacción
enorme pero una dosis no despreciable de
verdad en causar algún daño a veces
hacer poco o nada puede ser una opción
más medicina no siempre es la mejor
medicina gracias
[Aplausos]